And now it's the old Scoutmaster.
Hey, did I ever tell you the one about the Scoutmaster's bunk at summer camp?
Well, it hasn't been made up yet.
Oh yeah, it's really, it's come to this.
Hey, this is podcast number 365..
Hey,
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
We've gone through three or four podcasts in our foundation series
And over the next three we're going to wind it up by looking at
and talking about three main things: about scouting,
about playing the game, patrols, advancement and youth leadership,
And these are the key pieces that occupy most of what we do as
Scouters and make scouting what it is for young people.
What we're going to do is ask ourselves why they're part of scouting,
how they are intended to function and what our role is in making them happen.
This week we're going to be talking about patrols.
Remember to get in touch with me with your comments and questions.
I'll tell you how to do that towards the end of the podcast,
But for now, let's get started, shall we?
And now, ladies and gentlemen, a multifaceted man of many spigots,
a human soup bean, and they give him on his own time.
There's a quartermaster. everybody knows.
There's a song about him. this is how it goes.
Just a little diddy doesn't mean a thing,
But when the boys are marching how they love to sing,
There were mice, mice eating up the rice in the stores.
In the stores there were rats- rats big as blooming cats.
In the quartermaster store.
My eyes are dim, I cannot see.
I have not brought my specs with me.
If you'll remember, one of the things that I've said somewhere within this series of podcasts
is that Scouting presents us with one goal and one method.
The goal is to develop character. the method is the patrol method,
And it's likely I'm going to do what I always do,
and that is use the terms patrol method and patrol system interchangeably.
But in a little bit I'm going to differentiate between those two terms.
But just stick with me while we figure a couple of things out first.
So step one is asking the question: why do we even have patrols?
And when I first became a Scouter, I looked at the whole patrol method thing
and was happy to have it operate in this kind of vestigial manner
that the Scouter's prior to me had been doing,
which is it's basically a way to administer a larger group
by dividing it into smaller groups.
that seemed to be the reason that we had it.
But if you look back at our history,
and you just look back at the principles upon which Scouting was founded,
you see that this is not the key reason.
even though it makes sense administratively to take a big group of people
and divide them into smaller groups to better manage them,
that wasn't why we started having patrols.
So let's jump into the way back machine here for a moment
and look at what happened when Scouting started.
And forgive me if you've heard all this before,
but Baden Powell, the founder of Scouting, is a British Army officer in Africa
during the Boer War.
He achieves a certain fame back home as a war hero.
He writes a book about the methods that he used in South Africa
and he calls those methods Scouting.
He comes home to Great Britain to find that people involved with youth
are using this book and is encouraged to write. Scouting for Boys
and foments a worldwide phenomenon.
There is no Scouting movement.
There is no Scouting organization.
There's only the book and the idea.
Basically, what happens is young people get the book
and they just start doing Scouting.
and the way that they do that is by making up a patrol,
and there's a great story about this,
told by a fellow named John Thurman,
who was one of those young people,
and I want to read you some of that story.
Thurman wrote: in the early days of Scouting,
boys from all over the country, and later from all over the world,
bought the book Scouting for Boys
and formed themselves in patrols.
I want to repeat, formed themselves.
This means that someone- a leader,
not appointed by anyone in particular,
but chosen by other fellows
because those same other fellows were willing to follow him-
gathered around himself a crowd of chaps
who wanted to be scouts.
They formed a patrol and they started to train themselves
using the book Scouting for Boys as the only God.
but they found- as patrols have always found-
that there were many things they did not know,
many things they could not find out
and many things they could not do
without the help of some adult.
so the practice grew of a number of patrols
getting together, forming a troop
and usually finding their own scout master.
So this is why we have patrols,
because patrols are the basic unit of Scouting.
We didn't begin with troops and with adults being involved.
we began with young people taking the book,
forming themselves into patrols
and then finding out that
well, we could have some advantages
if adults were involved with this
and we would have the benefit of scale
if we brought our patrols together into a troop.
Now the rest of this story is told
in a post on ScoutMasterCGcom
called Why Do We Have Scout Masters?
and I will link to it in the podcast notes.
but in our discussion of the patrol method
or system,
I think this is all very helpful
in understanding how to
apply the patrol method.
See, Baden Powell
saw that young people
formed their own little gangs and groups
and thought that this would work out well
and set the number at around eight
because that just seemed to work really well.
So the patrol was just the natural
affiliation group
that a young person would normally form anyway,
and this was the basis
of the entire Scouting movement.
Now, if you've been around for a while,
you've probably heard these two terms-
patrol system and patrol method,
and most of the time when we talk about it
they're kind of interchangeable terms.
I want to differentiate between those two terms
and separate them into two different approaches,
and you're not going to find this
in the literature anywhere.
This is just my own way of looking at it.
What's the difference between a patrol system
and a patrol method.
I'm going to say that we can use those terms
as shorthand for two different approaches
to how we work with patrols.
If we work with the patrol system,
we're paying attention to the administrative idea
of having a big group
split into smaller groups,
represented by a central body,
and it's purely an administrative tool
used for convenience and efficiency.
In contrast, when we talk about patrol method,
we're talking about the processes
of discovery and development that happen
within a patrol
or a small group,
because the patrol method
doesn't just apply to young people
in a scout troop,
it also applies to
cubs and dens and venturers and crews.
The system part
has different administrative terms,
names and practices,
but the method part is the same.
So let's think about the method.
Back to Thurman's story.
In the story
Thurman talks about like their first camping trip
and it's hilarious.
They made plenty of mistakes,
they tried out a lot of things
with mixed success.
So what happens in patrols
is there's a thousand little
interactions and things
are popping and moving along
and this is the way
character is developed,
or you end up
with the Lord of the Flies kind of situation
where things go downhill very quickly.
So our role is to
make sure the first situation
happens and prevent the second.
and the way that we do this is how?
think about it for a moment.
It's an easy answer.
It's the ideals of the scout,
oath and law.
It's encouraging our scouts
to follow those ideals
and put them into practice
in all of the interactions
and things that they have
with their patrol.
Now, if you've been following
through this series,
you've gotten the sense-
along with me, hopefully-
that all of these things
are incredibly simple things
and a lot of times simple things
have this kind of oxymoronic
nature to them where they are
the most durable. yet
they're also the most fragile
things about a given system.
As scouting developed
into a worldwide movement,
the organizational imperatives
began to change and morph
and usurp, in some cases,
some of the original intent
in the way which this was all set up.
So a digression for a moment
to explain myself,
because I've talked about
scouting organizations in all of this,
in these foundational series,
a couple of times.
So let's be very clear
about exactly what I'm saying.
You've no doubt come into scouting
through some kind of
an organizational setup.
If you're in the United States of America,
you've probably come in
through the Boy Scouts of America
or the Girl Scouts of America.
we have to understand that those
organizational things
are going to warp and obscure
some of the more simple things,
because keeping organizations
aimed at the individual
in the small group is a really difficult thing to do.
Now, interestingly,
none of what I have shared with you
runs counter
to the policies and rules
and procedures of any organization
that I know of,
and, at the same time,
most of what I've said
does run counter
to the culture
that's been established within
in those organizations
about what scouting is
and how it functions.
I think it's important enough
for me to repeat that
None of the advice that I'm giving you,
none of the
way that I'm describing
how scouting works in this
foundational series,
is intended to,
nor, in fact, does
run counter to any of the policies,
procedures or rules
of any scouting organization that I know of,
but it often does
run counter to the culture
that that organization has created.
The culture that organizations create
is kind of a macrocosm
of the things
that each of us as individuals
brings to the scouting program.
If you have a background in academia,
if you have a background in business,
if you have a background in the military,
if you have a background in the trades,
you're going to bring certain
understandings of the way an organization
operates,
whether it's a national organization
or a local organization,
or your scouting unit,
whether it be a cub pack,
a scout troop
or a venturing crew.
you know, if I
put you into a room full of 40 young people
and I said, okay,
present them a scouting program,
while you would begin with the way
that you manage things,
with your understanding
of how to bring order
and effectiveness
to the way that this is all going to work.
so those are all administrative
and organizational imperatives.
but the patrol method
goes a whole lot deeper
and it's a whole lot more important
than those surface things
and its importance is its simplicity
because I will say,
I'll repeat myself again-
the real reason that we want to have patrols
is that the interactions
within that patrol,
when they are based on the ideals of the scout,
oath and law,
is the key way,
the key stage
for character to be developed in our scouts.
and we've been encouraged through training
to examine the way small groups work
through some stages of development
like forming and norming and storming,
and it's all rhyming and it's great.
but forget about it,
because
the intent and reason
that we have patrols
is not that they become a high
performing subset of a broader organization.
now, that's very likely to happen anyway
without our intervention.
but that's not the reason that we have them.
remember why do we have them?
everyone?
because that's the environment in which
character is built.
and when you examine what a patrol does
and how they do it,
you will likely be
dissatisfied
and you need to manage that
dissatisfaction
by living with it,
mostly
because this is not a flaw
of the patrol method.
this is a feature
a patrol full of young people
is pretty much always storming,
is pretty much always chaotic,
is pretty much always searching for
even the basic
elements of organization
and coherence and skill.
and it's fine,
that's the way it's supposed to be,
because it is within that search,
it is within that process of discovery
that our scouts develop a character.
so here's a t-shirt that you can get
and hand it out to all the adults in your troop.
it says: don't fix that,
leave it alone.
the game is being played,
it's working.
this is how things happen.
this is what we're aimed at.
this is what we want to see.
I'm not talking about
anarchy and violence and horror shows-
those you stop-
but just the day to day,
the feeling around
trying to figure out what's going on,
the process of discovery,
of working together,
of resolving conflicts,
of trying to figure out
what leadership means
and how to follow leaders,
and how to put one foot in front of the other
and one stick at a time
on the fire-
all of those things
that we think we ought to fix
are the heart and soul
of what we really want for our scouts.
that thought
perhaps embodies
the most practical advice I can give any scouter,
which was said to me
in a statement that's always stuck with me
by a friend of mine who is a scouter with me:
let them live their own lives
now. believe it or not,
this is highly practical advice.
it's just probably not
what you really want to hear.
you would rather me talk about
your agenda for a patrol
leaders council meeting,
or how do you select patrols,
or how does a patrol like patrol leaders,
all of those other
practical things.
well, I've written about those,
I've spoken about them before. they're not hard to find
at scoutmastercgcom.
but as you look at
the materials that you're given by your scouting organization,
as you look at the administrative plans
at the patrol
system,
remember
the patrol method
and preserve
rather than promote the patrol
system.
once again, I really want to hear your thoughts about all this.
get in touch, ask me questions.
it's easy to do
and I'm going to tell you how to do that in just a moment.
thank you for listening to this
365th edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
it's easy to get in touch: just go to
scoutmastercgcom.
you'll find the blog there.
you'll find an index to all the subjects
in the blog. over 1500 different
posts
and 350 plus episodes of the
podcast are there. you can join us on
social media- on facebook and twitter,
and you can always email me directly
at clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
c-l-a-r-k-e
at scoutmaster
c-g
com.
I need to remind you that I am not endorsed or sponsored
by any scouting organization.
I am just.
you know, I have a microphone
and a way to make a podcast
and this is how I help my fellow scouts.
if you'd like to return the favor
and offer some support to scoutmastercgcom
in the podcast,
just go to any page at scoutmastercgcom,
click the support
link at the top of the page and you'll find out how.
I want to make sure to thank all backers
and patrons for helping make
all of this possible. and before we
go, let's hear from our
founder, Sir Robert Maden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
why? thank you, sir? until next
time, everyone.